i can't believe that you never interned
for me because i i turned it down a lot
no
i know how bad you guys wanted why
didn't you want to work for free we need
that in turn no but they say that he's
so good the list of people from the
office i know it's crazy who are from
massachusetts that was an option when
though they were talking about it on set
i felt so left out i was like why did my
mom never tell me you're a mother i
don't know no but it's like you know
like others just go to the summer camp
and you're like wait i didn't know you
could do that but when i was a kid like
kids went to concerts i'm like how did
you go to a con like your mom drove you
to the worcester centre and waited in
the car oh my god the worcester centrum
yes i didn't get it yeah these kids go
to nirvana when i was like in eighth
grade i was like you can go um and so
yeah i was like no one told me you could
intern at conan
yeah
and and when you think about it i think
half the cast of the office yes interned
for me interned at the office
[Laughter]
he also had to intern at the office when
he first got that's how low down he was
um
[Laughter]
all right you can fast you can play
michael but you also have to intern for
the first year you have to get dwight
coffee
[Laughter]
so weird and it worked against the
character prep too it was
not the right dynamic yeah so um so but
you must have i mean i know you're
friends with a lot of the people that
interned uh for us who who what's the
list of people that internationally yeah
kenzie mindy kaling crazy john krasinski
uh ellie kemper yeah well i mean am i
leaving anyone else i think that's it
yeah i think some are going to end up
interning for us
yeah still yeah there's a lot on the
podcast uh i think krasinski when he
gets his comeuppance will be here
getting me coffee again yep i loved it
the last time i saw krazynski i think he
had a bodyguard and i'm thinking you
used to get me coffee
and now there's someone here to protect
you from me
i don't blame him i don't blame him
either i'm a very violent man yeah he's
a lot enemies um
i've always heard that mindy kaling does
this thing that uh i want to ask you
about which is something that is near
and dear to my heart
um making confirmation
making up lies
that um
don't really exist for any reason just
making up a very random lie yeah it and
it's kind of a way of pranking people
but it's something that's always
fascinated me um i love that as well and
i'm a big believer in that but can you
give me examples is it true first of all
yeah well she now and then she hasn't
done it in a while i hope but um
she told me she really needed money yep
and i gave her a hundred thousand
dollars that's how she started so she
started giggling yeah
she told that to warner brothers all
right sure
um
she once on the office told me that um
there was a female director
that um had done an episode of one of my
scripts and i didn't especially like how
the direction went not a huge deal but
mindy said that she had used to date
greg
the director the director used to date
greg
and um also we're at like 24. so i
they everyone looked like a grown-up
this woman was
like 20 years older than greg i was like
oh okay all right and so then greg was
like what'd you think of her as a
director and i was like
yeah she was good
so we hired her back
but i should have said like i not my
favorite director and then later i told
him like you used to date her right and
he was like what are you talking about
she's like sick no
um how would i have anyway when someone
lies
and the lie doesn't have a point yes and
then they act like they gotcha she never
acted like she got me it was just a
private joke which is even more pure i
have to admire the the comedian that
doesn't need an audience just her and
god okay i don't know what you're
talking about canadian doesn't have an
audience uh you've gotta you've gotta
score that feels like a fellini movie
yeah i've been around people sometimes
who say uh
yeah on my way in today a pebble you
know shot up from the road and cracked
my windshield i got to get it fixed and
i'd be like huh that's too bad they'll
be like no it didn't
that's not [ __ ] you
wait a minute that's that's it i missed
out here well sony you've done that to
me plenty of times always with a pebble
i i'm sorry i love that pebble bit and
you fall for it every single time yes
you fall for it every single time i mean
the key to it the pro and con is that
it's so mundane but there's also no
payoff and people think they're who
would lie about such a thing right
but uh huge waste of time yeah so so she
that's something i see i like that about
mindy i like that she's willing to take
you down she cares about comedy yeah and
she's an amazing hard joke writer too
yeah yeah
um i think those two go hand in hand i
think so too yeah